let me go to x trumpist is it x trump is
from rhode island
uh yes hi david how are you good how are
you
good so i was a trumpist in 2016.
okay um mostly because i live in rhode
island
and my vote for that uh race didn't
really count
um but also because hillary was just
so awful in the 90s okay wait a second
you're you're telling me two different
things and neither of them makes sense
let's see if we can let's see if we can
figure
figure out let's go go one at a time
here so
your first assertion was because you
lived in rhode island and your vote
didn't matter you voted for donald trump
explain that to me well rhode island has
never gone
red yeah really yeah so
it was more of a throwaway vote i didn't
really expect him to win
um so it was more kind of a uh a joke
vote i guess you could say
and who was the joke on um just more
i guess myself really that's i think
that's exactly right i think that's
perfect i think you realize
you really only it was you were really
only joking with yourself perfect okay
we're gonna clip this guys
um second part was yes you voted for
trump because hillary was awful in the
90s now did it occur to you to compare
hillary in 2016 to trump in 2016 or were
you comparing
hillary in 92 to trump in 2016
um it was more hillary the whole nine
whole 90s so 92 would be part of it i
guess
and why and why did you do that how did
you decide to that way to vote
um honestly i don't know you're not sure
i think it was just still it was
really more for the last 20 years so
including the 2000s
and were you worried at all about the
things trump did over the last 20 years
uh yes but i didn't think when he got
into office that the
republican congress would be such um
well just be politically you know nice
about it on the air um they wouldn't
list a weak willed
and have no backbone right i don't think
it could be this
bad as far as um
authoritarian authoritarianism authority
yeah
yeah and is it is that authoritarianism
the reason why you flipped
from trump to biden uh yes i don't
really
care for biden as far as
um i don't think he's as
liberal as i probably would have wanted
to kind of swing things the other way
wait a second let me let me back up for
a second here so hold on
so you're to biden's left biden's too
conservative for you
which means hillary's also too
conservative for you right
it's more of a it's not like a straight
left and right thing with me i'm more
like libertarianism
um like towards that end
but socially to the left of him
but even though you're to biden's left
you voted trump over hillary that's a
very interesting very very interesting
uh yeah and just to be totally upfront
with me are you trolling me right now or
is this for real
oh no it's for real it's for real okay
good all right no listen guys
this is sociologically important i think
that this is very very interesting i
really appreciate you uh talking to us
today
yeah welcome can i just say one thing
also sure um
uh very strongly i would say that hot
dogs are
sandwiched okay um tacos
are not a sandwich they are a failed rap
okay
um yeah that's all i have to say all
right thank you very much appreciate
that
guys